Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Unforgiving: A Northern Hymn.
We just came face-to-ass with a giant troll, and it didn't go so well for us, in fact,
We might be mentally scarred about that,  but now that we got our brother back we're gonna be able to sneak our way through these trees and get our way through- Uh, Oh
Oh No
What are you talking about? What could possibly be wrong? Ooh-
The hypnotic ass of death, okay, alright, okay, alright.  You lead the way, bro!
I'll follow you to the ends of the earth - and then I'll probably die but besides that- Oh, where'd you go? Geez
I wasn't paying attention
Oh, wow. *chuckles* Wow uh,
*chuckles* Uh- It's- uh it's quite a walk you got there, bro. You're, uh, you- you're really working out those glutes
I can see. The quads are burning quite deeply, but I dunno bro. I mean, maybe it's friendly
He seems awfully friendly
Munching on whatever the hell it's got there. HEY!
HEY BUDDY! ya doING great. :D I mean you smell really bad
AND UR FAMILY PROBABLY HATES YOU AND NO ONE WANTS TO BE AROUND YOU
And you should probably INVEST in some DEODORANT
You know personal hygiene is obviously not high priority for you, but you're doing great keep it up, man
I'm proud of you? not really. I don't know- oh, thanks for waiting, bro
Yeah, I can see that walk didn't get you very far mMM
Oh boy that guy is ugly, and I don't know what he's munching on
But it's a slice- wOW I was going fast all of a sudden
Oh should I be not- okay, alright nevermind. It's time to run, I guess. Okay here we go then
Thank you Bro
For giving me warning about that one... now where the hell are we going? Is the question. Like how did he survive on his own?
I barely know how I survived on my own, in fact if I remember correctly, I didn't survive on my own
Oh, now is the time- it's safe for flashlight? You sure about that- Oh, hi
Wait there's more than one?
Yeah, no joke we gotta keep movin, but wait, what is it? *Mark tripping over words*
Have those been different ones that I've been seeing or- I thought it was the same one
ah
So we're running into a distinct problem
If there's gonna be more than one of those big tall thingies because there's also other monsters in the woods
And I feel like you should be worried about that- you know I never understood how trolls reproduce so
And and you know what I guess I don't want to find out their den of- uh oh, we're going in-
We're going into their den of pleasures as I was about to say. Yeah, bro. I ain't too sure about this either
I'm sure we'll be safe in there
This obviously looks like it's made by natural occurrences and not by a giant troll biting its way through the ground
Oh, can you imagine just a giant worm with a troll head just like blasting its way through a mountain? *Sound of disgust*
No bueno, no bueno. Uh oh-
Hi, okay.
Okay
Thanks, bro
Man, I love hanging out with you. Sure do love our vacations where you kidnap me somehow mysteriously near a-
A horrible troll infested Island. That's my favorite
type of the day that we have together.
Oh no, the bridge is out. Well, who built this bridge? Because that's the biggest question that I have right now
There's a ton of infrastructure on this
island
And it had to have originated from somewhere. Are you waiting for me?
Really, bro? Do I have to go? All right fine. Slide- Aw man my butt is taking a beating in this game
I am sliding all over the place- Oh, hey, how's it going there?
I guess you don't need to slide then. Yeah, it's so bizarre like the
elements that are in here are obviously from a time when industrialization was a thing. There's like mining equipment, there's rail yards
It's not exactly modern for like the time period where we all have cell phones
I'm assuming that this game is set in modern times, but there's still an element that's missing
Like why is all this here?
Where could they have been possibly going that there would have been human civilizations that didn't know- notice the giant
naked trolls
walking around
completely big floppily swinging all over the place
And no one noticed like not a single goddamn person noticed that there were giant rolls and also shadow monsters
In the marshes of which people built bridges
And it was like a car thing and a big old box train that moved across the ocean
Like those are things that didn't just pop up people built those along with their
sacrifice books and what not and what have you
*loud in-game growl* AH THAT'S NOT GOOD
You don't need you don't  need to tell me!
Bro run faster. bRO. Uh oh
Whoa hey!
That's no good
Should I look back? WHOAHHH I SHOULD NOT LOOK BACK
Okay, all right. I- I'm aware of that, bro. I'm aware. How about you go faster, you douche?
I'm going. I-I am!
Currently going! Yes, that's exactly what I'm doing. Why would I, bro?
Honestly- Oh *Loud snapping/crushing sounds*
Was that the sound of my brother's bones snapping or was that-
Okay, this is the most horrible thing I've ever seen
What?
No!
Uhhh
What do I- Ohhhh, what do I do?
OhH
Why- Oh my god- Why- No- what in the hell was that all- Why did I do that?
Why? Oh, oh my god. Why am I doing this? Why in the world?
Why am I do- Why? Why?
Why?
Why did I-?
Why did I do that?
Why? Why? For what reason did I pull out his
eyeball and his tongue? What Swedish tradition is that? 'Cause I am not following that- I have no idea
Oh, I have- I have no idea. I am at a loss
I am completely in the dark. This whole
situation- I don't know what- I can't- Why can't I move anymore? Well,
I can't- Suddenly I can't even move, my mouse is dead, that is the answer to that question.
Excuse me, I have to- But I'm still gonna talk about what- why
What- What in the world
it's in and why- I have no idea like why- I can understand like
mercy killing, but I guess I left him to suffer too long and then he died anyway
And then I didn't help him and so and in my madness and my grief. I like
I pulled out his eye
So I could build like a bone effigy to- to keep him in my heart I guess??
I don't know if that's true
Ayeeee Ayoouuu Ooh-ahh Muuuuaaa
That's- that is a level of
I'm not sure. I got get a good a USB cable to charge my mouse. I just- oo it's wireless mouse
This is gonna- Is this long enough? I don't even know
I had a longer one. I don't know where it went- okay
alright
Carrying on, game on, all right. Okay? What does this say- "Quarantine! High risk of infection!"
Okay, alright. Well, I got a tongue to protect me and my brother's always watching over me
Because I got his eyeball
That's what I got
His eyeball
Okay, it is dark. I can't see shit
What is that fire on the mountain? What is that ? Is there a volcano over there?
Ay yi yi. okay. I'm over it. I'm over it. I've- I've recovered. I mean. I haven't recovered recovered, but I've recovered enough that
Well, I mean no I haven't reco-
I don't think anything is gonna make me recover that- I've played been playing horror games for years and that that just I think that
That finally messed me up. That messed me up. Okay. What do we get here?
*Reading*
Lovely story. *Reading*
Apparently that was newsworthy
Apparently that was front page news worthy. Ah, *Reading*
*Reading*
"Odin's knowledge", okay. Thank you for that, Odin. You are of great help, Odin.
Ah there- wahhhhh
Some light reading, yes, I guess, okay, all right mmm-ah
Cans of rust, I see. My favorite delicacy in these trying times
Ooh, that's horrible. Not that, this, that's horrible. Yep. That is horrible. "I want her!"
I don't. Can we just agree to disagree on that one? Cause, wow, that's gonna give me nightmares
Okay, there's a key though. Got a key, and a tongue, and an eye. That's really handy.
Okay, ugh, this is a scary room. Ah.
Yep, and the music kicked up. It's a bad room
Yep, this is a real bad room.
I don't know what's with that statue in the window, but that's bad. That is very bad. Don't like that.
Sacrifice again- Do I have a flashlight or anything?
You want to run that by me again?
Hey smarty pants, and you are giving me an idea what the hell is making that clatter out there, huh?
You guys want to do with that?
Oookay
All right, I'm outta there. I got a key though, that's awfully nice for me
Nice tiny tree- Uh, nope that's a- that's a- that's a human tree
Okay, you know what?
Nope, I'm gonna go with the big "Nope" on that one.
Ah, Helberg- phone- Oh, an outhouse! Double good for me- looks like it's all coming up
It's like it's coming up markiplier over here
*Mark imitates a noise* I can do that too
Want to do that together? And of course, do you want to start a band, huh?
I love that the out house has a little heart on it- Little window so you can see someone's taking a shit
*Imitates noise again*
Okay, I'm gonna- *Noise* over here, you guys *Noise* that away. I'll keep *Noise*-
I don't know about that. I'm pretty smoking hot- you can't even get close to these looks. Hey,
You don't know what kind of crazy I am- I ripped my own brother's eyeball and tongue out.
You don't want to know how badly I will mess you up if you come near my man
Alright, you can have him. You- you know what? You can have him, you- you can have him. I'm not that pretty- I'm pretty ugly.
I'm plain like any- Any definition
All right, okay, ah
Matches? Ah!
Excellent, I like that. Give that a good shakey shake. Ah, good, excellent, all righty, I've got matches which is
*Mark imitates another noise* What you say? All right, gotcha, light a match.
Light her up, baby. I've got a match, all right. What do we got here?
Okay. "She wants to keep me".
Sure, she does, whatever you say buddy. All right. Okay?
Hello? How are you? My brother's dead.
Yeah, I don't trust literally any of that- literally none of- Okay!
Well, my- my match just burnt my whole hand off. That's what I can assume happened there
Alrighty, then, I'm gonna crouch down and go through this hole in the ground cause that's how I roll, baby
Anybody else want to give me a rough time here because I am so ready to kill anybody that tries to get in my way
Not out of some vengeance just because I'll be so scared. I'll just come out
Wing it.
Oh
Hi, hello, how are you? Okay? Well, that's awful. Oh, what happened to your fingers?
I mean, what happened to the rest of you, but what happened to your fingers? Okay? That's awful. That's terrible. aAh.
Pony, ah, nice ass, okay, all right. Good great great great. I uh okay
I think I know this song all right you guys- you guys ready for it?
Are you ready for it? Ooh- *Reading*
*Reading* Okay, all right, wait, hang on- *Cue weird Mark noise and song*
Ow, mah fingers. *Noise*
That not do it?
Did I not get it? *Weird Mark noise*
Okay, all right, I'm outta here, all right
All right, see ya around the ben, I guess
Okay, all right, see ya I gue- Oh,
I got all the musicians coming with me on this trip
I'm gonna light that candle those next to that tree person
and I'm pretty sure they're not gonna light on fire and die horribly screaming, and then I'm gonna feel bad about that because
To be perfectly honest, I don't feel bad about anything these days considering the things I've already done to survive
Oh you mean, I didn't need to do that to survive. Oh, that's weird. Okay. All right, then whatever all right
Let's light that bad boy up all right. Give me a give me a good old light on that
Yep, this is what I wanted
I don't understand how that worked, but all right I
I don't want to sing that song- you'll hear that
Okay all right, okay all
right horrible horrible very horrible uh
Horrible yes extremely horrible
Incredibly horrible the worst thing I've ever seen yep all the above. I'm gonna go with all the above is what that is
Okay~
Uhh- I- I should check the outhouse first before my candle runs out
Anybody in here? Anyone body taking a shit- ooh, me, Molly. Okay? All right. Good job
Molly glad you think so highly of yourself to put up
self-portrait by the shitter. Ah,
it's dark in here
Why did that one take so many tries? I don't like that
Hi, please tell me that was an animal. "it's everywhere"
What is? Fire?
Uh-huh, okay. "Rut Alkvist".
"The vanishing of Rut Alkvist", but wait this is for Rut Alkvist right here-
What does that mean? Oh, a lighter in this room ey?
*Reading*
righty-ho whoever the hell Grimnir is
God thaaaat
What's in the bottom drawer
Nothing, all right
"Sacrifice". They sure do love their sacrifice here
Don't know what that was
I don't even know how to- Ow, my hand
Hang on, do I even need one of these
Why not? Oh well makes me feel safe hello, ah
Lovely I see you gave the baby booze oh, no, that's a doll
Beer bottle I don't want to play in the forest anymore. Yeah, I wonder why
everybody got turned into trees which is kind of bad ah
A spittoon- Perfect. Can I wear this as a hat?
Mmm, maybe I should take my hand in here to really see if there's any buried treasure down deep something tells me
There's some good to be gleaned from that all right. What do we have here? Nothing. What do we have here? Ah?
besties for-
Yup besties for all Ted forever indeed homeschooling teaching children in the home is
Yeah, okay all right hymns and birds
Love hymns and ballads so I got bored with that homeschooling thing. Oh good. It's someone doing kettle bell trick. Oh
God that joke was so spicy. I had to drop my match all right
Sploosh alright, let's get out of this hellhole. We don't need to be here anymore. I got places to be
Now what am I looking for exactly? I I think I'm looking for some kind of an instrument. That's gonna help me
play some music that's gonna help me get across a bri-
Get across a bridge and hopefully get to where I need to go, because the year may be
1942 for these people but for some reason magic still works nowadays, oh hey lady, you're so..
Sassy. Kay I'm gonna move on, alright, see ya, yeesh- Oh!
Hello?
And how is there still power by the way that's another big question than I have here did I go in some weird time loop?
some weird time thing
Okay alright lady alright. Hey over here for a good time you say, okay alright. That's
Disturbing as hell. Oh my god. That is the worst thing I've ever seen yeesh
Yep, that's oh. I hate every second of looking at you
Yep, every single second of looking at you is the worst thing I've ever done. Okay, all right
well you have a lovely day being a horribly transformed into a
monstrous tree person
And I'll have a lovely day trying to figure out a way to get into this house. That's locked for mysterious reasons
Everybody should know that privacy goes out the window when you've got
horrible demons at the door
We don't have a key?
Gah, how do I get into my inventory?
Eh, whatever, okay? I've got yae many matches. I don't know what that is, but I got yae many. Okay. Oh wait, no, wait
Wait, did I make a big circle or something? Oh? What is this? Hello? Altar? Oh?
weird
Alrighty, then - two, good, okay
Mmm. Lovely, oh
Okay, all right
Hmm. Little ones of Freya. That's nice. Clock tower? Very sassy
Phone? Mm, I don't believe you
Drawbridge. Uhh, storage. And Hall of the ha- *Sound of realization*
So is that the Clock tower? Okay, so that's the Clock tower. That's where I am right now, so I need to go
Smeb, I need to go to find the blacksmith. Oh my god.
Can it be true? The rumors! Are they really real?
Probably not, you know, but here I go anyway. Can't believe I'm finally finding the bla- Guys!
I found the blacksmith! After all these years! I can't believe it!
SMED! Oh, come on, Smed! My good buddy S-
Things sound a lot creepier when you whisper them in Swedish
Hello?
Anybody in here?
Mr. Blacksmith?
Smed, good buddy?
How you doing Smeddy? Oooh! I got an ellastic band or a rope or whatever that might be
Yeesh, nice cup.
All right.
*Reading*
Is that a good thing or a bad thing? Is- What? What? Don't you have- *Reading*
Yeah, have them all piecing together what's newsworthy in this- in this town
"Oh, we found a woman walking around. She was naked."
"I don't know why"
Yeah, I thought printed on a newspaper
Oh good. Oh, what the hell a chimney? Oh, it's buried. Okay? Well this was pointless
I'm glad I finally found you after all these years, but I can't help but say
mildly
Underwhelming my friend okay, so I gotta find- I gotta find a
Okay, all right,
That's an option to do- How about- Have you ever considered not that thing that you just did? Which was creepy and terrible and gonna
Give me nightmares
Have you ever thought about that one? No? Okay, all right. Just- just suggesting it. You know- Oooh, what is that?
Oh, that's new! Oh, I didn't notice that! Oh
Oh- What is- What am I even leaving looking at? What am I looking at? Ah!
Oh, that's a- it's a dead thing. Oh, that's what that was. Okay. It's a dead whatever- It doesn't matter what it is-
It's a dead thing and those are-
That's bad, because that's recent then
Great, okay, alright. I am in a weird time warp.
Okay, alright, glad we clarified that, I'm gonna go to the hall of the harp now. The little ones of Freya. I'm sure- yaAA
All of my worst fears have suddenly been confirmed. This is the worst thing.
The little ones of Freya are gonna haunt my dreams as I remember in the previous horror games that I played such as like dead
space
Okay, all right,
okey-dokey then
All right, you have fun doing whatever the hell you're talking about
I'm gonna go over here now
I'm gonna go into this place and be very scared
probably
Hello?
Little ones, have you all been taken away?
Ah,
A yo-yo!
All right, is this another chamber pots?
Or spittoon if you will- Oh, good, blood on the walls, that's wonderful
Cinnamon bun recipe
Fun
On a bun
Are those?
Thank you. Ah four. Yes. Thank you. Oh, a goat! Nice goat. Okay. All right. I wanted to get out of here now
*Spooked Mark* EH, what was that?
Ooh
IIIIIII don't like it. Okay. All right
I'm gonna go in here now. Hello?
Ah, more spittoons you know all these- Oh, he comes at night. Oh, that's
Okay, no, yeah, I don't like that. You know how uh?
These kids love chewing tobacco
All right, what do we got here? "Mommy's crying?"
Mommy's crying, but someone else is happy! That I can plainly see.
What was that?
oh
Oh boy, oh boy, these people-
*Ominous music picks up*
*Baby Cry*
Nope. Nope!
*Distressed Mark* Ahhhhh! "Mommy doesn't believe me, but I saw him"
I think I believe you
Oh, I hate it I hate it I hate it I hate it I hate it I hate it
I HATE IT
I hate every bit of it! I hate everything about this place!
AGHH
AGH
Okay, that's all the time I got for this episode
I'm gonna carry this on. I'm gonna go to the hall of the harp
And then I'm gonna see what all the fuss is about over there, but thank you everybody so much for watching
We're gonna get through this together
We're gonna get through it
Slowly, but surely, so thank you everybody so much for watching and as always we'll see you
in the next video buh-bye!